hey guys welcome to a brand new video
today I'm gonna be testing out a
money-making method in the brand new
revenant caves Wow everyone is there
killing revenant
getting decayed just having a [__] fest
I'm gonna go sneak in and make some
serious Bank so what I'm going to be
doing is exchanging the new ancient
items for cash did you actually do that
in the bounty hunter world so originally
found this just by looking at the wiki
and then I want to go look at G tracker
which is a sponsor of mine go check them
out there'll be a link in the
description for that and we just go look
at the ancient items here and you can
see they are fairly substantially below
the amount of cash value you get for
them like the ancient statuette you're
getting 40 K on the ancient emblem looks
like 25k ancient totems 40 K which has
some serious potential I have no clue
what the money per hour is gonna be yet
but I'm really excited to try okay so to
start off here I'm gonna go in Scout the
bit with my main I just cuz I'm less
likely to die so my idea here is I would
like to go here on a level 3 account
will not be very likely for you to get
decayed however that is on the basis
that the Emlyn trader is at the top of
the ruminant caves because there
actually is no monsters I think between
there and where he I saw him the one
time I've been here once and the win in
the southern entrance and ran away
through to the north Ness where he was I
think he roams around but we'll have to
go check hence why I'm scouting so he
can use the burning amulet to get here
multiple ways I guess we'll go to the
lava maze entrance now so we'll teleport
here and if I die it won't be huge deal
but let's see where the entrance is from
here okay so it seems to be that dungeon
map here so it's really not that far of
a run and although the southern entrance
is a little bit closer but I really
really hope he doesn't me and ER that
far away because it'll be such a pain to
go and try to actually find him
so we said Edmond here not too bad for
monsters we got some green dragons that
would be a bit of an issue so I'm gonna
plan on bringing three emblems at a time
so for one we have to double check if
they're kept on death should be but so
we're gonna run here and probably get BK
this which I come in here hello and oh
he's all another 23 so running the top
here now there's a [__] Allah people P
Kane here and we're gonna quickly hop
world's here so we have to be in the
bounty hunter world so we'll hop again
and the last time I saw him was actually
up here so [__] there's a lot of people
there but they're all level 90 around
there anyway and that's where I saw him
last time so boy there he is right there
okay so we found the emblem trader and
this is world 318 so that's definitely
doable we will just have to hope he
stays here so we'll log off and we'll
hop onto my flippin account so as far as
the emblems this is what I managed to
buy we got twenty ancient totems we put
these in a while ago so they finally
came through which we're looking to get
836 K profit on each one I've got two
ancient statuettes which is not that big
a profit probably not worth it for these
ones in ancient emblems obviously the
ancient statuette being the highest risk
and ancient emblem being the lowest risk
and just the best risk versus reward
from this item anyway so we'll go ahead
and claim all of these statuettes and
ancient items here so the first test and
what is actually fairly important here
is will it actually keep on death we can
only bring three at a time because I
don't have to protect item prayer okay
so it looks like well take off our
[__] top hat and monocle but it looks
like these will keep on desks so running
there won't be an issue it's only gonna
be once I trade them in where the big
risk is however I am only a combat level
3 in theory I should really only be
decayed by a dragon or something else
that might just whack me for a solid
amount hopefully we can actually avoid
everything here so we're gonna run past
the admin guy here so for someone to
attack me here they'll have to be 38 or
local goddammit here's the caves and we
are in and we got all 30 of range of
emblems too which is nice okay so this
seems pretty good so far so hopefully
he's just there because otherwise this
will be a problem [__] bastard left
so new plan unfortunately I'm gonna come
here my main now the new reasoning is
most of the revenant cave is below level
30 wilderness
which would be reducing my risk
substantially because really only gonna
be risking something for a couple
seconds and once I have the cash I can
teleport out instantly and I'll just
leave my alt up here in case for some
reason he ends up up there anyway
because he actually moves around a fair
amount I think this may actually to be
done on the main or someone that can
actually tank the damage so it actually
took me a while to find in the first
time but after this I should be able to
do this much quicker because he should
stay relatively in the same spot or at
least not move so far because I can get
back here pretty quick okay so we
exchanged our emblems in and let's get
the [__] out of here quickly and yeah so
you're only really at risk for 2 or 3
seconds and you can kind of look around
and make sure nobody's there ok so we're
gonna start off by a cashing in some of
the more riskier emblems because I know
if I end up losing 8 mil at the
beginning the video is probably better
than at the end we almost have a video
done so we'll go in cash in the more
expensive ones first the most I'll be
risking is 8 mil and that is for like
one and a half seconds so I think it's
worth the risk
but like I said earlier the statuettes
were actually not really worth it for
the risk kind of reward now that I have
the emblem trader pinned down and I can
actually completely run in under a
minute so he really doesn't have enough
time to run around and I get lost so I
can actually teleport and do each one in
about a minute run back talk to him
again and you could theoretically
probably do 60 of these runs an hour
probably not quite that many but maybe
40 would be totally reasonable
just using the burning amulet to the
band that camp in run in from the bottom
of course if he's further to the north
you might consider going to the lava
maze [__] up here into hell board foul
or however at that point if it's at the
top you might not want to consider doing
it just because it's now in 30 +
wilderness and you actually have to run
a bit with the cache before you would be
able to tell her out realistically you
can probably just wait until he runs
down or Scout a bit and to see if he's
in the correct spot because it really
really reduces your risk when you're
doing this method I'm really only
wearing just black tea I just some
defensive armor that's not work
much because I didn't want to lose even
a hundred K on the weight but honestly
could probably wear better armor because
I was not attacked at all people's ran
right by me you just really have to look
like you or scouting and you have no
clue what you're doing and you're just
kind of running back or maybe you're
running back to grab your gear that
you've already died really people just
didn't bat an eye at me but they were
focused on the revenants they're focused
on killing people killing the revenant
and they didn't even know that possibly
the most valuable kill was right there
if they managed to they could have
probably got eight mil in one go but so
I wasn't really sure how long it would
take to do but currently I think I'm on
pace to do all of my items in about 15
minutes I've already gone through all
the expensive ones now where I just on
to the ancient emblems now which we
should be through very quickly we'll
only have like eight more to go through
and that will be it at first it didn't
seem like you'd be able to get through
the chat options in time but actually if
you're kind of running in whatever
monster egg rows you you can actually
get through the options in time as long
as you're not standing still if there's
a little bit of a delay can actually do
it pretty much right on cue just gonna
have to go space with space space space
and then hit the one button as an
immediately teleport out yeah that's
pretty much it guys so we're gonna go
ahead and see your timings about 15
minutes that is pretty damn good if I
don't say so myself and we'll go ahead
and see how much we're actually gonna
make an hour I'm really excited to check
this out
alright guys we finish up our runs and
it only took 15 minutes to do all that
way way quicker and I thought it would
be the main benefit here is that when
you know where the location is you can
get back so quickly that he doesn't have
a chance to move around that much but
now how much did I make in 15 minutes
and how much could you theoretically
make in an hour here well in 15 minutes
I made one point six mil and I didn't
even buy the items at the cheapest plan
I even could I went ahead and checked
just after doing this and they're even
cheaper like I can get a 50k margin on
at the ancient emblem and 50 K on
another one I was only getting 25k on
the majority of my items and 30 cans
some and I still made 1.6 mill in 15
minutes so we multiply that by 4 for how
much you could do in an hour that's six
point seven million sane I don't expect
it to say this way forever however it is
probably the best money making method
possibly in the game currently assuming
you can actually buy the emblems at a
proper price nobody I didn't die once
like nobody even tried to kill me at all
the risk is actually relatively low the
only really at risk for two seconds or
like one second for one you can actually
look around you and make sure that
there's nobody there and the likelihood
of someone logging in like tile blocking
he was very very very slim and I think
it's totally worth the risk
hey guys I hope you enjoyed the video I
had a lot of fun making this I just
really didn't expect it to be this good
but honestly if you bought the items for
even cheaper you can probably get
upwards of like 10 mil an hour it's
ridiculous thanks for watching guys I
hope you enjoyed if you did don't forget
to toss a video like always nice and I
will see in the next video